[Music]
a lot of head bobbing around me i'm
going to toss it right over the black
and take it away he feels good when he's
fighting his lips i was biting my lip i
had the uh overbite going for some eve
stefani uh all right because we're
talking about serena williams let me
blow your mind serena williams one of
the best tennis players ever and a
businesswoman to boot now she is
cementing her mogul status she announced
this week her venture capital firm
serena ventures has raised
111 million dollars to invest
early stage startups 111 million big
ones williams team says it wants to
empower people who have often been
overlooked in order to create a more
inclusive economy while it doesn't
require founders to come from
historically underrepresented
backgrounds the group says 76 of its
portfolio heads do it's already made get
this more than 60 angel investments in
companies like masterclass the food
delivery group daily harvest impossible
foods and others talking about hitting
the ground running right it's ready to
go so she also had an interesting tweet
uh she wrote this on twitter no matter
how far we've come we get reminded that
it's not enough that's why i raised 111
million dollars to support the founders
who are overlooked by ingrained systems
because of this they put a picture of
my penis i know that's in the new york
times that's in the new york times the
paper of record send the memo all black
people do not look alive
they got the memo they did
so to be fair yeah they share 50 of
their dna i mean
but they clearly don't look the same she
wrote because i am overlooked serena
williams is overlooked she said new york
times you can do better yes
congratulations serena